basically you're not allowed to breathe
unless you take their permission I want
you to watch a few clips of me
especially this first one where you see
Muslims and Christians standing together
in solidarity against Injustice For
Justice
[Music]
it's very sad that the Christian
zionists have forgotten about their own
Christian Brothers but it's the Muslims
who are still standing by next to them
caring about them and who care about us
the Muslim the Muslim Palestinian they
care more than the Christian in the
world so our brother they are the
Palestinian Muslim not the Christian in
the world for those Christians who are
supporting this oppression against their
Christian Brothers they're not following
the way of Jesus the prince of peace
some of the most basic uh uh rights
human rights are not given to us neither
are those who are denying their basic
human rights following the example of
Moses my name is Maran harp I'm a
Christian Living in Palestine ble when I
hear that Christians in the west are
helping Israel thinking that they are
helping Christians in Palestine I think
uh there mistaken Israel is who to blame
they took everything now they took all
your life since you're a child following
the example of Moses No actually they're
not they're following the example of the
actual atheist the satanists who
developed this movement the Theodore
herzo and his gang and the like they
took everything now they took all your
life since you a child now these are the
Christians speaking because usually
you'll think okay these are just Muslims
down there who are being oppressed but
these are also the Christians they won't
even give them Brea air to breathe
basically you're not uh allowed to
breathe unless you you take their
permission I really want you to imagine
someone controlling your electricity
food fuel even your water they control
how much water we get so we get the
water like one days in the month so this
is a big problem no one know about that
and no one care about that you often
hear this slogan often just repeat it
it's the only democracy in this part of
the world but what do the Muslims and
Christians what's the heartbeat of the
people have to say about this I would
say that's the biggest I've
ever had freedom of movement freedom of
speech Just freedom in general we don't
have it this is the situation here
Christians and Muslims are suffering
it's not Justice in here it's not
democracy in here we are treated like a
low class people here in uh in this
country in Israel we face all kind of
discri discrimin ation everywhere
wherever we go I feel like I don't
belong to here you are asking Israel if
it treats Christians or Muslims
different no it's exactly the same you
are under the same occupation you don't
have like a human being rights and is
this all Christians generally or anybody
who is like not Jewish I think now if
you're wondering where this is at this
is in the heart of Palestine in
Jerusalem where when Muslims I know most
of you don't know history but if you
check into the history you'll see that
for over a thousand years when Muslims
rules Jews Christians and Muslims live
together in
[Music]
peace the Muslims protected the
Christians protected the churches and
that's why churches are existing Muslims
could have destroyed you know all of the
churches and killed all the Christians
800 years ago go to Bethlehem scene
shops beside the others Muslim and the
Christian you know the Middle East you
know and
uh this whole area you know many
minorities lived under Islam you know
even Jews you know we all know the Jews
were
protected by Muslims in Morocco Algeria
and Tunisia from the Christian
Inquisition you'll often hear this term
jizya being repeated by the islamophobic
industry the hate provocators no they
did not pay taxes you know when the
Muslims came something that's pretty
much nothing it's nothing of a tax
compared to what you're being taxed
today and what they're actually imag
right now so you got nothing a very
minute tax very you're paying taxes all
over the place everywhere you go you're
getting taxed but look to what they're
doing to them with these type of
extortionary tactics and taxes that
they're hitting them with that nobody's
talking
[Music]
about church has been closed because uh
the Jerusalem
municipality uh charged the churches
here a tax on the property tax which is
about $190 million after 50 years she
changeed the law and make us pay taxes
from the beginning of the Israel
existence till today when the Israeli
government closed Thea MOS there is a
lot of Christians was standing side by
side with Muslims same as well when they
closed the Church of polyer you could
find a lot of Muslims are standing with
their brothers Christians with the
height taxes will become a very heavy
burden on Christians well they just like
living on Don Nations they can't pay
taxes and it comes down to one thing and
it's not a religious thing the whole
story is about one thing the Israelis
stole our land that's the whole story
it's political problems not religion
problems now for our Christian friends
colleagues and neighbors who are seeing
this right before our eyes you've often
heard the slogan never again but you're
seeing it happen right now what will you
do about it will you speak out will you
say something but you say I can't
because it's part of my Creed I'm sinful
if I do well you've been brain you've
been duped you've been fooled it has
nothing to do with these Endtime
prophecies false teachings that been
pushed on to you by many of these
pastors and Evangelical
Christians and the like I will bless
those who bless you and the one who
curses you I will curse why did God
choose Israel let's look briefly at
Bible History I was amazed to find now
when interviewing a Christian Pastor
himself and looking more into this this
term dispensationalism or it's skull
field ISM this was this actually was put
together by a con artist someone who
spent some time in jail came out got his
DD and then got these teachings from a
John Nelson Darby and they put these
into to the scoffield reference Bible
and then it was funded by this or
Zionist organization and then they put
this out into millions of churches were
given this these teachings the scoffield
Bible and over the years it grew it grew
it Grant some it got some traction and
it was pushed into into books and into
series Christian series and now it's
become an industry it's become an
industry this whole fake madeup end
times prophecies and now they're
connecting certain verses that for 1800
years it was never connected to the
modern Zionist State not at all and
you've been duped you've been fooled so
it's up to you you can stay fool stay in
the stay duped or you can look into this
a little bit further because I guarantee
you that this is actually this goes
against Christianity has nothing to do
with Christianity we don't have to sit
there and sing a kumbai of course there
are differences we as Muslims we love
Jesus we rever him as a Mighty
Messengers just like Abraham Noah Moses
and the list goes on Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon just the last and
final messenger they all were brothers
of one another delivering the same
message of submission to the will of the
one Creator God Almighty in Arabic Allah
and the Christians there the arabic
speaking Christians they also say Allah
they call on God Almighty Allah the
creator of heavens and earth so of
course there are differences but the
commonalities are much much more we have
so much more in common so you can be on
that side that focuses on those things
that we have in common you can discuss
the differences you can agree to
disagree but you agree that we should
live together in peace try to preserve
our families this is what Muslims want
this is what the Christians want down
there this is what history has shown
before these these lies that are now
perpetuated that it's Muslims against
Christians and Muslims against Jews and
all of this is
hogwash all of this is propaganda that's
been pushed out there deliberately to
try to divide
us and I hope that you can see through
this thank you very much for tuning in
subscribe hit that notification Bell if
you haven't already so you can get
exciting informative programs like this
sent to you thank you peace be with you
assalam alaikum I cannot leave without
giving you a gift if you're not yet
Muslim and you're tuning in to see what
these Muslims are talking about and you
like a free copy of the Quran go ahead
and visit theen show.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 1 1800
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum